savez peut-être ils ont été créés
imaginée par le dessinateur jean michel
folon est aujourd'hui pour commencer
cette nouvelle année
antenne 2 vous proposera tout au cours
de ce 1er janvier de retrouver l'univers
de jean michel folon à travers des
chansons interprétées par jacques brel
par claude nougaro par yves montand
également des chansons qui ont été
illustrés par des films d'animation
créée par jean michel folon vient pour
commencer notre programme télévisé nous
allons vous présenter dans un instant un
merveilleux concert un concert
interprété par herbert von karajan la
quatrième symphonie de tchaïkovski bon
début de journée sur antenne 2 à tout à
l'heure